be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while I play video
games and talk to you about random life
stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about the Four Horsemen of
apocalypse and what I'm hoping is that
at the end of all this you'll have a
strong understanding of the team as well
as how they fit into the overall
pantheon of Marvel Comics so the four
horsemen of apocalypse first appeared in
x-factor issue number 15 in 1987 and
were created by Louise Simonson and
while this is the first chronological
appearance of the group I want to jump
out of chronology and trouble back to
the early days of Apocalypse and the
Dark Riders in my video on apocalypse
explained we had talked about how he had
risen to influence following the
manifestation of his powers which
included super strength speed durability
and immortality
while his initial action was to run off
Kane the Conqueror a time traveler who
had been masquerading as a pharaoh in
Egypt in order to acquire apocalypse in
the early days of his life and use them
to conquer the world following this
origin apocalypse began traveling the
world hitting various societies against
one another in an effort to eliminate
the weak and ensure the survival of the
strong during this time apocalypse had
laid the foundation for future societies
and that much like the Romans who would
come thousands of years later apocalypse
made soldiers out of the conquered
society strongest members referring to
themselves as the writers of the dark
the army swept across the world like a
plague conquering territory after
territory all in the name of apocalypse
who would use the terror of their
existence as a means to inspire fear
among the weak in addition to this and
the four part series apocalypse versus
Dracula written by Frank Thierry and
released in 2006 apocalypse and his
writers of the dark had encountered Vlad
the Impaler whose historical influence
on the world under the moniker of
Dracula was brought to an end when the
writers to the dark had killed him now
while this bit of history also
contradicts existing information like
1982's bizarre adventures number 33
which depicted Vlad being killed due to
false visions which led him into a
battle that he couldn't win what we do
know is that because the time traveller
Cable had sought to destroy apocalypse
before he can merge with celestial
technology during their first encounter
Cable had laid waste to the entirety of
the writers of the dark after which he
defeated apocalypse leaving him for dead
now while apocalypse himself would
survive and use cables blood as a means
to communicate with the celestial ship
and take on the various powers that he
possesses today
following this transformation he had
begun his conquest anew but with the
idea of using a celestial ship to modify
the genetic structure of those he
considered worthy transforming them into
agents of his own will while this time
period did not actually see him
reforming the writers of the dark were
taking on another team of his own it did
see him encountering individuals like
Nathaniel Essex and Bennett dupe Harry
transmogrifying both men and a mr.
sinister and Exodus respectively while
either giving them powers as was the
case with Essex or enhancing their
powers as was the case in Exodus
regardless since apocalypse is required
to re-energize himself every few
thousand years in order to ensure his
powers operate at peak function we can
largely assume that at some point
between his encounter with Exodus and
his first appearance at x-factor issue
number five he had left the Marvel
landscape for this purpose but reimagine
an effort to begin another conquest at
world domination taking place an
x-factor issue number 10 with Apocalypse
recognizing the surge and mutant and
superhuman development as well as the
various powers that came with him unlike
the days of old when fear was enough to
seize control of a country the world had
grown accustomed to seeing individuals
like the Avengers spider-man and others
all of whom while not strong enough to
challenge apocalypse on their own can
easily topple his reign if working
together as an example in 2013 as part
of his run on uncanny Avengers writer
Rick Remender had offered a backstory
which featured apocalypse and Thor doing
battle which ended with apocalypses
near-death after Thor attacked him with
a magically imbued axe known as Giambi 1
looking to ensure his success and taking
over the world with x-factor issue
number 10 going through issues number 26
Louise Simonson tied the series and to
existing Marvel crossovers but featuring
apocalypse as a background character
mustering a group of beings who would
serve as his agents and represent the
Four Horsemen of biblical scripture
taking place in the mutant Massacre and
event crossing over within the pages of
x-factor x-men daredevil for New Mutants
and Power Pack while the main story
focused on mr. sentenced you're viewing
the Morlocks within the tunnels of New
York as failed experiments and
instructing gambit and his Marauders to
eliminate them during this time
apocalypse approached a woman named
plague who have the power to enhance and
spread disease looking to take her on as
the horseman pestilence because the
Morlocks exist is castoffs due to the
physical deformities or extreme powers
which may
and targets for fear and hatred among
humanity apocalypse offered plague at
place it aside which continued the trend
of his ability to prey on the
weak-minded but also use plagues desire
to find a place for herself within
society following the deaths of so many
of her friends accepting his offer and
traveling to the celestial ship
apocalypses next appearance came with
the introduction of a man named Abraham
Curos as a mutant with the ability to
create explosive blasts by clapping his
hands with Abraham having been paralyzed
from the neck down during the Vietnam
War he was offered the ability to walk
if he agreed to serve as apocalypse his
horsemen war accepting his offer
Abraham was transported to the celestial
ship after which apocalypse turned his
sights to a young girl named autumn
Wilson because autumn had the power to
disintegrate organic material on contact
while her lack of mastery over the power
she possessed hadn't cost the lives of
anyone around her the fact that she
could lose control and kill someone
inspired fear among her parents and
children at school in addition to this
because project wide-awake had already
been launched as a joint venture between
the National Security Council the FBI
and the NSA with Henry Peter Gyrich
overseeing the operations and using
sentinels to round up mutants the fear
of autumns parents also gave way to
concern over not just the lives of those
around them but the life of autumn
herself to this end autumn was routinely
kept hidden away from the world and only
allowed to leave her home when traveling
to school as a result autumns hatred for
her parents and society at large turned
inward leaving her in an emaciated state
busyness to his advantage apocalypse had
approached autumn offering her the power
to seek revenge on her parents but also
master her own abilities and experience
a free and fruitful life accepting
apocalypses offer autumn was taken away
to the celestial ship where she
alongside plague and Abraham found their
powers augmented but were also
brainwashed soaring Failte to apocalypse
and has caused a survival of the fittest
now where these three had operated as
the first horsemen with apocalypse
looking to fulfill Biblical prophecy
live up to his namesake and inspire fear
throughout the world he sought out a
fourth horse going to take the role of
death eventually setting his sights on
Warren Worthington
taking place in the final pages of
x-factor issue 16 17 and 18 with one
having used his vast wealth to fund the
actions of x-factor and their efforts
alongside the x-men
in order to ensure the illusion was
maintained of x-factor taking mutants as
prisoners of the federal government
Warren Worthington brought his former
college roommate Cameron Hodge on board
as the team's public relations director
to ensure the public never became aware
an x-factor was actually handy mutants
over to Charles Xavier to ensure their
safety and training on the use of their
abilities however because Cameron had
come to view Warren with jealous eyes
due to born successful financially and
personally Cameron had begun to engineer
a series of plans all of which would
come to fruition with x-factor going
bankrupt disbanding and more an
Worthington died with Warren Worthington
being injured during the Beaton massacre
and that his wings were mauled to the
point that amputation was considered a
possibility because cameras Mecca
nations remain unknown to the team he
had exercised his position as the
group's lawyer to seize control of
Warren's fortune and have his wings
amputated with one coming - and
recognized that he had lost virtually
everything despite cameras to feed his
last act came in the form of Warren's
jet exploding bleeding x-factor to
believe the Warren had committed suicide
in the face of financial bankruptcy
while Warren had actually been taken
away by apocalypse in the moments before
the Jets explosion apocalypse offered a
deal if Warren would serve as his
horsemen death apocalypse would give him
back his ability to fly accepting the
offer without question
much like plague autumn and Abraham
Warren got more than he bargained for
and that he was brainwashed and came to
view apocalypse as the harbinger of the
end times
calling the week from the world
following this the various themes of
symbol by Louise Simonson came to a head
in issue number 23 with a Four Horseman
doing battle against x-factor now
because Warren possessed full knowledge
of the x-factor team having been a
full-fledged member of the original
x-men and experiencing their strengths
and weaknesses firsthand this
information came to use as he was able
to rally the other three horsemen to
strike x-factor in key positions
overcoming their extensive training and
pushing the team to near defeat however
with the mutant Massacre event still
seeing fallout x-factor was joined by
power pack a group of child heroes who
were led by Franklin Richards and used
their abilities to assist x-factor and
overcoming the four horsemen
during which time pestilence was killed
and warns bond was returned to normal
albeit tormented by his experience
battling his friends now while this
would go on to serve as the basis for
the future of Warren's care
character in his eternal hatred for
apocalypse with a four horsemen having
been defeated apocalypse retreated for
the purpose of regather Ingush forces
and attempting domination once again
covered an x-factor volume 1 issue 66
and 67 as part of the lead up to cables
origin what we're told is that at some
point following his defeat apocalypse
had traveled to the oxygenated blue area
of the moon and invaded Attilan seizing
control of a portion of the inhuman
populace and taking six of the most
powerful beings outside of the royal
family reforming the riders of the dark
it was revealed that apocalypse as vast
powers had the side effect of burning
through his body requiring him to use a
new host to keep his essence alive
coming to the conclusion that the
offspring of Jean Grey's clone Madeline
prior was the ideal candidate due to his
Omega level telepathy and telekinesis
Apocalypse had ordered the writers of
the dark to kidnap the child leading to
a battle between apocalypse and a full
contingent of the x-men x-force x-factor
and the Inhumans while the story would
see apocalypse driven off and nathan
summers taken to the future to become
cable the events also saw the writers of
the dark completely destroyed leaving
apocalypse to recover from his injuries
and reform a team for the third time now
following this particular battle as far
as I'm aware apocalypse never fully
reformed the four horsemen for a number
of years while there's no definitive
answer to this I would wager that with a
launch of x-men vol 2 in 1991 under
Chris Claremont and Gimli the original
x-factor team was rolled over into the
new x-men title with greater emphasis on
fighting villains like Magneto and
creating new content and stories like
the introduction of Avalon as an
asteroid ran by Magneto and serving as a
safe haven for mutants as well as fatal
attractions which introduced the
acolytes who were similar to the
horseman but were led by Fabian Cortez
and served Magneto
in addition to this with a launch of Age
of Apocalypse as a six month long series
replacing all existing x-men related
titles on the whole Marvel was looking
to move away from apocalypse as a
central villain and instead move him to
the role of a background character in
various stories as a result for around
five years between 1991 and 1996
apocalypse had no horseman of his own
instead his stories were isolated to
focusing on singular beans like strife
the future clone of cable as well as
stepping in to defeat onslaught at the
be has
of the watcher however because fatal
attractions had left Wolverine without
his adamantium and cent vol 2 of his
solo series plunging in terms of sales
underwriter larry Hama the decision was
made to restore Wolverine to the status
quo as well as set the stage for the
crossover story the 12 taking place in
Wolverine vol 2 issues 99 100 and 101
with apocalypse looking to reform the
horsemen Wolverine was kidnapped and
replaced with a squirrel replicate
allowing apocalypse to pit him against
Sabretooth and forming the two that
whoever won the battle would be as new
horseman death Wolverine proved himself
to be superior leading to Apocalypse
returning his adamantium and
brainwashing Logan taking the next step
and leading into the 12 crossover
because of story focus on the idea that
12 individuals would lead an uprising
against humanity apocalypse came to
believe that he alone was designed to be
the harbinger of this prophecy to this
end he had captured death bird the
sister of the Shiar empress lilandra
Caliban a fuller Morlock with a power to
track mutants and Rory Campbell who had
no powers but was given the ability to
drain the life energy of others all of
whom came together as pestilence war and
famine respectively and alongside wool
rain began the process of collecting the
twelve now we're this group consisted of
magneto and his daughter polaris
representing the magnetic poles Iceman
storm and Sun fire represent to the
elements Cyclops Jean and cable
representing the father the mother and
the son a bishop a Mikhail Rasputin
representing time and space with Charles
Xavier representing pure thought
apocalypse look to channel all of their
powers through the living monolith of
uten with the ability to absorb any and
all forms of energy giving apocalypse
the power to remake reality however with
Cyclops intervening and destroying the
process apocalypse MERS was Scott
forming a kind of hybrid being with
apocalypse and Scott vying for control
of the body now in terms of the horseman
because the post 12 cotton knew to
remove the traditional role of
apocalypse and have seen Rory Campbell
Caliban Wolverine and death bird return
to normal the concept of the horsemen
remained virtually unused for the
entirety of about 6 years between 2000
and 2006 the reason why was that with
Marvel facing major financial issues and
writer Joe Quesada coming on board as
editor-in-chief focus was shifted away
from attempting to keep interest in
older characters to revitalization and
revamping as a result this
to your window saw a series of massive
upheavals including the cancellation of
Avengers the start of New Avengers the
launch a civil war and the infamous
redcon of Peter Parker's marriage to
Mary Jane Watson and coming out of the
House of M which saw 98% of the mutant
population losing their powers
decimation served to provide a basis for
why the x-men maintain complete lack of
involvement in civil war and that with
the number of active mutants being so
low the x-men could ill afford to lose
anyone during this time and after having
remained in a rejuvenation chamber
apocalypse reemerged
claimed to have been awakened
prematurely due to the sudden drop in
the mutant populace looking to place
himself as the Messiah of Eton kind in
addition to demanding that humanity call
98% of its population to match the 98%
reduction in the mutant population he
began to reform his horsemen kidnapping
gazer a mutant with the power to absorb
all forms of radiation
Sunfire who could reduce heat similar to
Johnny Storm and Polaris who was capable
of manipulating magnetism in the same
fashion as her father magneto these
three took on the form of war famine and
pestilence with gambit approaching
apocalypse for the purpose of becoming
death now in terms of gambit while he
has been an x-man and fought against
apocalypse on a multitude of occasions
the argument he made here was at in
times of desperation you can kinda dally
der who had experience but was also
capable of doing things that no one else
would
with apocalypse having been in existence
for thousands of years and routinely
attempting to seize control of the world
his stance was that existing mutants of
the world had withstood the fires of
testing and prove themselves worthy
indicating that apocalypse would go to
any lengths to ensure their survival
against whatever threats they may face
however the story went on to reveal that
this act by apocalypse served a rally
mutants for the purpose of attending to
defeat the Celestials who were fast
approaching and bringing their judgement
to sidetrack here if you recall my video
on apocalypse explained we had talked
about how he had gained his expansive
abilities after striking a bargain with
the Celestials using their technology
for future payments of unknown
explanation as a result the conflict
between apocalypse and his forces saw
victory on the side of the x-men the new
mutants and Tony Stark's Office of
national emergency sentinels with
apocalypse fatally wounded looking to
death as a means to escape as punishment
and the moments before is passing up
pocalypse was presumed to be whisked
away to perdition by the Celestials with
a comic offering no indication as to
whether or not he would ever return
following this with apocalypse having
remained vacant for Marvel Comics for
around four years in 2010 as part of
recommenders run on the newly launched
x-force apocalypse was resurrected by a
servant Ozymandias and the history of
the four horsemen received a bit of a
red con what we're told is that were
previous information how that apocalypse
started forming the four horsemen in
response to the rise of the mutant
population instead the horsemen had been
an existing idea and those formed in the
original pages of x-factor were not the
first when apocalypse recognizing the
possibility of his own death should he
failed to stop the judgement of the
Celestials apocalypse alongside his
servant Ozymandias had begun to secretly
collect four individuals who were deemed
worthy beyond those who were normally
chosen to this end if the death of
apocalypse were to occur he would be
reanimated by Ozymandias and these four
horsemen would serve to ensure his
survival until such time that apocalypse
garnered enough power to return to his
role as a demigod seeking to rule the
world now as a group that existed
secretly and without the knowledge of
any of Earth's heroes aside from
themselves
Wolverine psylocke Deadpool Fantomex and
archangel function as the uncanny
x-force and operated more akin to a
black ops team eliminating the world's
problems before the public became aware
of the fact that those problems even
existed as such with apocalypse tanning
as an omega-level threat under the
leadership of Wolverine x-force sought
him out for the purpose of discovering
how far the resurrection process had
progressed and in what condition of hawk
elipse existed taking place in issue
number 4 at the conclusion of the first
story arc with the discovery of
apocalypse as a child
the final horsemen existed to protect
this version of apocalypse by whatever
means necessary now while their
involvement here is extremely limited
and then almost nothing was known about
their lives before encountering
apocalypse and that they were defeated
almost immediately by x-force the
depiction of these final horsemen was
that they hailed from all corners of the
world and came in the form of Decimus
furious who possess super strength
durability immunity to psychic powers
and regeneration which assuming from
Japan who would release a swarm of
flesh-eating beetles jelly who could
reduce sounds that would destroy the
flesh of those who heard it and San
Jorge ovide who can
in fact a single person or group of
people with lethal diseases of virtually
any nature with that being said because
of the fact that I have upcoming videos
for the apocalypse wars what I'm going
to do here is I'm actually gonna go
ahead in this video and what we'll do is
that once we get to apocalypse wars will
actually wrap back around and we'll talk
about that iteration of the four
horsemen most of whom actually consists
of members of the x-men themselves with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys later peace